having Oprah takes such a huge interest
in and the film process was was really a
blessing it was a godsend we think
people think that we're kidding and we
say this but on set we really did we
would pray before every scene and we
would also kind of pray to the God of
Oprah like person we didn't know how
huge role Oprah would play and our film
but we just prayed that she would that
which that she would approve of it mom
and I guess you know God works and so we
we got her approval and you know plus a
hundred folks from her and we're so
grateful that she that she took a liking
to our little film because what she what
her name does is so powerful and just
having her touch our film is like
turning it to gold
what's so inspirational about Oprah is
everything you know it's it's really
really hard for a woman to make it and
to be taken seriously and not only is
she a woman she's a black woman and so
that's kind of they say that's double
strikes but she she single-handedly kind
of refutes that that notion that as
women we can never make it anywhere that
black as black people we can never make
it anywhere she is so strong and she's
powerful she's really powerful and on
top of that she uses her power for good
she's got so much strength in what she
does with it to help other people to to
help other people learn who were you
know rich poor whatever any everyone can
be be helped by her and it's not just
her her hand but her story everything
about her is so inspirational I'm a huge
fan of the color purple I think that
Oprah should've got the Oscar for her as
Sophia a long time ago
I really have to hold myself back from
quoting her is I I want I'd probably
watch the color purple more than a
hundred times and I
usually like to watch a movie more than
once but every time it's on I watch it
like classic lines like girl child ain't
safe and a family full of mins like it's
amazing and just like all that I love
Harpo but I beat him dead before I let
him hit me I love that movie so much and
she's so great and just like when she
comes back from jail and she doesn't
speak because she's been beaten down for
so long and then when she gets to see
her her children for the first time
that's like primo acting like she opens
like a flower
she's so amazing in that movie she's a
person in the world she's not just a
person in America and so when she built
that school in Africa people were saying
oh why don't you build a school in
America and it's because we actually
have a better chance of having we have
schools in Africa they're deprived of
Education and in a lot of countries and
so what she does is amazing she touches
other countries not just her own not
just her own backyard you know because
she doesn't just care about American
people or she cares about people in
general which is we're just amazing and
a lot of people aren't a lot of people
aren't open mentally enough to do that
to do see a need and somebody else's
home and fulfill that mean